breaking tonight big news on president
Trump's Iran strategy within the last
few hours the president says quote he
couldn't care less if they negotiate
despite what his national security
advisor suggested this morning the
president reiterating his insistence
that Iran will not get a nuclear weapon
and urging the regime not to kill
protesters even as protests against the
regime continue to grow as thousands of
people took to the streets to condemn
their leaders for shooting down a
Ukrainian passenger plane in a moment
I'll be joined by Congressman Matt Gaetz
for reaction and we have a fantastic
lineup for you tonight to break down all
the latest news on Iran impeachment and
the 2020 race look at this
Tammy Bruce is here Lisa booth Lawrence
Jones katie mcfarland coming up on Iran
evening everyone and welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro community and of course
pro America on Friday Nancy Pelosi caved
again saying she'll send articles of
impeachment to the Senate in a few days
Iran yesterday admitted to shooting down
that Ukrainian passenger plane while
confirming that its response to
president Trump's strike on terror chief
Qasem Soleimani has concluded here's how
I see things at the end of a momentous
week for the Trump presidency and the
start of what could be another defining
7-days this show is called
the next revolution but tonight I want
to talk about the Trump revolution
because I don't think there's been
proper recognition of this substance and
significance of what this president is
doing it's completely different from
what we've seen before
it doesn't fit into the establishments
traditional ideological boxes and that's
why they waste our time with pointless
political games like impeachment we saw
the new approach clearly with Iran the
Democrats never Trump as and their media
lackeys lurched wildly from calling
Trump week to branding him a war monger
but his strategy has been consistent
from day one he's anti-war but he's also
anti weak no he doesn't want to invade
deserts of sand like the neo cons but he
doesn't want to put his head in the sand
like the isolation nuts either he was
the same
over Syria withdrawing troops from a
conflict that someone else's business
but a missile strike if you use chemical
weapons you saw is North Korea fire and
fury and then historic negotiations the
same with China tough Terrace but look
what's happening next week they're
coming here to sign a deal this is the
Trump revolution pragmatic
non-ideological he approaches issues as
a problem-solving businessman it's
actually a revolution in ideas and it
goes way beyond foreign policy he's
combining the best of traditional
conservative ideas with positive
populism appointing conservative judges
and criminal justice reform cutting
taxes and boosting family leave cutting
regulations by the way given a massive
boost last week with new plans to reform
the environmental bureaucracy that's
blocking infrastructure construction and
cutting low-wage immigration the result
well we know this story by now but we
see new chapters every month another
positive jobs report on Friday
unemployment again at a 50-year low and
here's the most important part earnings
rising not just for everyone but fastest
for the lowest paid ending nearly 50
years of stagnation so how are the
establishment Republicans reacting
Donald Trump ran as a celebrity and has
become the worst president in history
normal walking around Americans are sad
and embarrassed and exhausted the vast
majority of Americans don't think he's
doing a good job think he's a bad
president think he's compromised by a
foreign power think he's dishonest which
he is of course think he's corrupt which
he is of course it thinks he's lawless
which of course he is he is an awful
representative not only of the
Republican Party but the human race
just before the holidays the never Trump
established a manifesto in the New York
Times quote as Americans we must stem
the damage he and his followers are
doing to the rule of law the
Constitution and the American character
what trumps damage who backed the human
and economic
Tass trophy of the iraq war who brought
in the disastrous 1986 immigration
reform creating the broken system that
trump is trying to fix who let China
into the World Trade Organization
devastating American manufacturing to
the point where we literally can't even
print Bibles in America who pushed
ruling class trade globalism that
spawned the disastrous NAFTA putting so
many Americans out of work in the
heartland and who assaulted the American
family with policies that collapsed
marriage rates and family stability no
not the evil Trump it was you the
Republican establishment who did this to
America these never Trump Azhar
apologists for an elitist ideology that
is anti worker anti family and anti
community so they can write whatever
pompous self-righteous nonsense they
want in the New York Times the
establishment Republican Party is not
coming back it is dead killed by their
policy failure and Donald Trump's policy
success
there's no constituency for their ideas
except a handful of opportunists who
traded their principles for a contract
with the Democrats cable news networks
where they poop off about the
president's tweets while ignoring his
policies here's the level of their
analysis I truly believe he's the
hamburger eating Zamboni riding loon
that we see on TV and on Twitter
they're like pampered aristocrats in
pre-revolutionary France and powdered
wigs and fake beauty spots as they
Witter to each other my dear Trump is so
vulgar well maybe he is but if you're
someone who's finally got a job after
years on the scrap heap you'll take that
over elegant failure if you're a patriot
who's finally seeing America stand up to
China and defend our borders you'll come
to the same conclusion after Trump it
will be a different Republican Party and
for American workers families and
communities that is fantastic news